once we we were doing elders and the
most recent thing you learned was
something to do with what we what that
was I also helped me Oh Mike turns yeah
I just what else wanna know just what
else wanna tell me what I like - did you
tell me
I can't find a ski gentleman come to the
light they give you an example so for
example I think these terms like these
terms
well like each other they both how are
they like terms are they like terms
they're not like terms
okay so there's a couple of things that
I notice about these correct they are
not like terms the first thing you've
noticed is there's like this
multiplication happening in here isn't
there it's kind of kind of happening on
the sly this is really shorthand for
three plus three times egg isn't it okay
so there's not just that third the big
thing that I'm looking for that makes
these unlike is that you can see this
algebra hanging out here is a pronumeral
a variable and unknown we've talked
about these times before and over here
they just have a number right so these
guys are in fact on like what if I
change this just a little bit
it's chucking in something like this
okay now I have like terms right which
terms are the like terms
yeah at the back Daniel fantastic the
three and the five okay they are alike
because they're both just numbers no
algebra attached right so I can and this
is what you did very very silly with
these like terms I can collect them
so collecting like terms was the most
recent skill that you were developing
okay so this would be equal to 8 plus 3
okay let's change one more thing that's
add another like term onto there
suppose I said let's do must be really
interesting let's chuck this on the end
of everything okay now again another
like term but because it's got algebra
and it's got the same per normal as I
have over here these guys have like
terms now right makes it 3 a + -7 a
really important to cancer there's a
minus sign there right and the - kind of
hangs along like a like a bad smell to
the 7a okay so 3 a and a - 7 a so when I
put you together when I collect them
what do I get
fantastic well I'm ready so I'm gonna
paste - full and that's that's how I
would use collecting my tips okay now
one last thing to notice when we put
together this 3a in this - 7a the A's
didn't disappear it didn't become like
minus 4 is it oh I've got a gonna take
away a right there's multiplication
hiding in there all right so what this
is really short for is a plus a plus a
and this is short for what's it shuffle
hmm yep okay class but except except
it's a it's a minus sign isn't it right
so B minus a minus a 7 one more time
here we go
sometimes okay that was collecting like
terms but now when you step it up a
little bit and you have to be careful
because some parts of this are similar
and some parts are quite different
multiply and dividing terms is what
we're gonna do and even though you can
see on your textbook these are broken up
into two separate exercises they're
really the same idea because division is
just multiplying in the verse okay so
let's have a go at these right let's
pick up white at question
you're gonna go straight to will do a
together first we'll do a few of these
okay
so please read me it's not gonna take a
huge amount of time right the question
who's me five times three one okay now
when you are multiplying these things
together in some senses it doesn't
matter anymore whether they're like or
unlike because we're multiplying or
dividing to go together alright so here
I can think about these numbers right
this is really short for well tell me
again what's 3y and abbreviation off
yeah fantastic
5 times 3 times y like you just told me
okay so now you can see I can multiply
these in any order I like so I might as
well put together these two numbers cuz
I mean I'm good at Queen to you know say
5 times 3 is 15 X so I can do 15 times y
but I can just say why on earth some
thunk I've multiplied together
everything sort of jammed together in
one piece let's skip over to M so I've
got 2x
you always have to take something value
when you lend something
I took his driver's license okay I know
he had to come back did you do all right
we're worried sorry 2 X 2 X you remember
we did a little bit of a note on how you
shouldn't write your ex's like x just do
whatever you can to not confuse them
with each other 2x x 8y okay he doesn't
need right now again this time without
writing it just doing it in my head I'm
gonna remember but this is 2 times x
times 8 times y okay this is one long
dinner there's a word that starts really
P that's the result when you're most
plans together remember it's called yeah
a product fantastic this is just one
long product this transistors this times
this etc okay so if it's 2 times x times
8 times y I'm gonna put the two NBA
together at the front right and then
I've got the X and the y hanging out at
the end because I usually put my prayer
nails at the end it our medical orderly
nice so now you can tell me once it's
gonna be equal to 16 X Y now the X or
the Y let it go away right then it
disappear I don't know what the numbers
are equal to so I just have to leave
them there they're still unknowns
ok let's go for a trickier one let's go
for let's go for our because that's a
bit of a it's a bit of a pain
yeah me too
so kgs don't Morgan thank you would be
totally a careful son but it's not
alright now this one is a bit trickier
and you have to be very careful with
them in fact to help you if you have
another color it's not necessary but we
should be helpful at least I find it is
ok I've got three Pro numeral to you
H J and K in kind of this reader
arrangement right so what I want to do
is I want to work out how many H's do I
have and how many days and how many
caves okay now at this time like I did
before I'm gonna write it out in
longhand to make an obvious point okay
so what's this thing really equal to its
H times J times K times but you get the
idea
it's write out the whole thing okay and
the reason why this is so helpful is
because this will help us get the answer
right how many acres are that's the
first letter really how many ages oh I
see two one two so with my other color
I'll do something like underline them
now I've got two HS oh but I'm not
adding the memo right I multiply them
sir that's exactly right
so really H times H is H square very
good it feels like it should be all I
got two H's to H but you get two H if
you were adding them all right I'll just
write that appears in h plus h is 2h
right but H times H is H squared right
and it's a really subtle looking
difference but when you write out all
the multiplications that you can see oh
it's H times H okay so that's the first
thing I'm gonna write H squared okay I'm
not done yet
how many J's are they that's the next
thing I know medically there are three
I'll do this I'll make it a little bit
differently so confusing them okay
so circle is
J & J right this example is simple
enough you can a client you can kind of
do it in your head but we'll get to
examples where it's like wanna learn you
need to do everything you can to help
yourself
make sure you don't miss any terms okay
Serna three J's J times J times J Triple
J okay so what should I write
it's J cubes very good right it feels
like all three J's I should write three
days but you're not adding them you're
multiplying them so Jade cute last one
you probably get the point now how many
keys are there is two K there and okay
man you can use like a day of limes and
Kenneth so case way thanks baby
done there you go say we put it all
together there are no actual numbers
that we know what they are there's no
fifteen or sixteen hanging out the front
that's all we've got
question okay so you could put times
here in time see if you liked what
generally when we put the letters
together to save some space we don't
write the multiplications okay we do we
do that with pretty rules we don't do
with numbers though because if I wrote
five times three as five three with that
that means something else doesn't it so
you can't just jam numbers together but
you can jam / nails together cuz we're
not confusing that with oh yeah you do
that
that number H J I love that that's my
favorite number now
we know that that means H times J